who am i getting the good to go from
good to go okay thank you uh everyone
for joining uh minister dixon dr henry
and i here today on the traditional
territory of the le conga speaking
people the esquimalt and songs first
nation
and i'm not surprising anyone by saying
the past two years has been a burden on
all of us wherever we live in british
columbia indeed wherever we live around
the globe
but here in british columbia we've shown
that if we work together we can overcome
adversity and by following public health
orders and advice looking after each
other looking after our neighbors
looking after our family members we can
do just about anything even in the face
of a global pandemic
these measures that have been in place
for the past number of months to address
the omicron wave have been challenging
for many many people but our approach
since day one
has been to ensure that the restrictions
we put in place are absolutely necessary
to protect people going forward
and that remains the case today and
we've managed through this latest wave
of the pandemic again by following
public health orders and continuing to
use tools like masks when we're indoors
safety plans at our workplace and of
course the bc vaccine card to ensure
that everyone that we're interacting
with has done everything that they can
to protect themselves and to protect
those around them but today i'm pleased
that we're in a position to say that the
restrictions with respect to social
gatherings and public events will be
lifted effective
11 59 tomorrow and i'll leave dr henry
to go through the many details that are
involved in that decision but it's again
the balanced approach that we've taken
as a government with the best public
advice we can get from dr henry and her
team
that allows us to ease these
restrictions at this time and look
forward to brighter days ahead so that
we can get back to the things that we
love that businesses can get back to the
the hard work of uh making a go of it in
a tough time but i also want to say that
uh minister ravi callan and i and dr
henry uh briefed over 150 business
leaders today and the general sentiment
is a positive one because from the
beginning we've tried to ensure that the
restrictions that we bring in based on
advice are as passive as possible to
meet the maximum outcome which is the
well-being of our fellow citizens we
have the strongest economy in the
country we have we've seen wages
increase
year over year over the past two years
as well as ensuring that we have low
unemployment and an economy that works
for everyone there are significant
challenges ahead in that regard and
they're not affected at all by these
decisions today but we're going to
continue working with working people
with businesses and others to ensure
that our economy can continue to grow
and benefit all of us
what had got us here again is that we
listened to dr henry and her officials
you listened as a group collectively as
a province to the good advice we wore
masks when it was state when it was
important to do so and we got vaccinated
in record numbers and minister dix can
talk about the unprecedented and heroic
efforts that front line workers made to
ensure that all of us could be as safe
as possible by maximizing those
protections through an immunization
program that was unparalleled quite
frankly across the country and to all of
those who are in our acute care system
all of those who have worked tirelessly
to make sure that our supply chains
remain open than 90 percent of truckers
that have been going back and forth
within our communities and across
borders to bring important and essential
supplies to our front door i thank them
and to all of you who have been patient
and tolerant of some intolerance over
the past number of weeks i thank you as
well
we can agree to disagree but we should
not be disagreeable
i believe all british columbians have
gone through tremendous times over the
past two years all of us have made
sacrifices and i believe it's that
collective effort that's put us in the
position today where we can relieve
these restrictions and look forward to
better days ahead and with that i want
to thank again dr henry for her work and
allow her to finish off this
presentation by giving you some of the
details on the restrictions that will be
lifted effective at 11 59 tomorrow
thank you very much and good afternoon
as as we all know covert 19 has brought
challenges to all of us
and i am so grateful for everybody in
british columbia who has stepped up
and done what we needed to do to protect
each other to protect ourselves to
protect our communities
and i'm trying to move this forward but
it doesn't seem to want to go yet
try that one
wanna help that out
okay i will talk while we're doing this
where we are today is because of what
we've done in british columbia over 55
percent of our eligible children have
received their first dose over 90
percent of people have at least two
doses of vaccine and
over 50 percent of people have got their
booster dose and that's something that
we need to continue
and thankfully we're starting to see now
that transmission in our communities and
the the subsequent hospitalizations are
starting to come down
we are in the place that we are and
we've made these decisions based on the
best science based on the data that we
have of what's happening in british
columbia right now
and we are able to make the changes now
as a result of the efforts that people
throughout british columbia have made to
get vaccinated to follow all of the
public health measures and to take steps
to protect ourselves and those around us
so today we're going to continue that
transition is there
is there some way that you guys can
advance this
ah there we go all right so let's uh
let's move on to the next slide
and it is as i said because we did the
right things for each other and
particularly because of the high rates
of protection we have through
immunization that we are in the place
that we are right now
and if we can move ahead
yep
this is just some of the images and uh
we'll go through these quickly because
we want to get to the meat of it so the
next couple of slides are reflections
from people in our community of why and
how important it was that they were able
to get this protection not only for
themselves but to look after those
around them and particularly as we know
those who have been most differentially
affected by this pandemic including our
seniors and elders and if we go to the
next slide
how important it has been in so many of
our communities around the province that
we've done this for each other that
we've worn mass when it's important that
we've stayed away when we're not feeling
well and that we've got vaccinated so
where we are right now if we go to the
next slide is we are shifting our
response to a long-term covet 19
management strategy that's focused on
those key things that keep us safe
including immunization
and focusing attention on the things
that we do for ourselves based on our
own risk and the risk in our community
around us and the specific actions that
we all need to take to protect those
most at risk of severe infection and we
know that remains our elders our seniors
people who have immune compromising
conditions but we also need to move into
recovery as we're in this transition
phase we are not out of this pandemic in
british columbia in canada or globally
and we know there will be continuing
pressure on this virus to mutate into a
new variant a variant that may be more
may cause more serious illness a variant
that may evade some of the immune
benefits that we have right now but we
need to continue to monitor as well the
balance of our population health that
the restrictions that we have in place
have caused
and then we need to be ready to respond
to the ongoing waves and troughs as we
get through this next few months with
our very high level of of community
immunity and as we move into
the next respiratory season in the fall
but our goals remain the same if we go
to the next slide and that is to
minimize the number of serious illness
and people dying of covid19 and to
protect our health care system
and importantly to minimize societal
disruption and we are at a place today
where we can take major steps to do that
we still have important tools and we
have more and more tools now we know
that immunization makes a tremendous
difference we also have data now that
tells us that that booster dose protects
not only from serious illness but it
also protects us from infection it's not
a hundred percent but good data here
that's being presented uh even now by my
colleagues at the vccdc dr skarvonsky
and her team has shown that getting that
booster dose pretty gives you an
effectiveness of 60 percent against
infection with the omicron strain that's
important that means we'll reduce the
chances of getting infected and passing
it on to others
our public health measures some of which
will continue
will need to continue for the years
ahead we've learned how important it is
to stay home when we're sick to wear
masks on those occasions when we're
around people indoors we're our testing
strategy physical distancing in certain
situations and it may be important to
develop to keep our case and contact
management systems going for the next
strain of this virus that arises
we have all learned about infection
prevention and control in health care in
our workplaces and we will need to
continue to manage outbreaks in high in
settings of high risk of serious illness
whether it's long-term care or
corrections or others
and increasingly we have another tool of
treatment that can prevent
people who are at risk from having more
serious illness
if we go to the next slide vc is one of
the most vaccinated jurisdictions in the
world and we also know from the modeling
that we've done
looking at the sero prevalence studies
that we've been doing systematically
over the last two years that we have a
very high level of population immunity
right now and that's primarily because
of vaccination and a small amount from
people who've had a recent infection
we do know that an infection
particularly with omicron can cause a
varying level of immunity that may wane
quite quickly over time for some people
we do know as well that if you get
infected with omicron on the top of
having vaccine that you get a very
strong booster dose response from that
infection and you're very unlikely to
have more than a mild illness
so those are the things that put us in a
place right now where we can move ahead
on some of the other activities
if we go to the next slide we can see
compared to jurisdictions across canada
that we have been effective in our
approach and this is just looking at how
we have managed to come through the last
few weeks with our omicron wave we have
managed to keep our hospitalizations
lower so that we can spread them out and
manage and not overwhelm our health care
system and that's because of the
measures people have taken
to to protect themselves and others
and our deaths
remain low
it is the same if we compare ourselves
to other jurisdictions around the world
in the next slide where we see as well
that we've been managed
by the work that people have done
collectively
if we go to the next slide again
this is just a comparison of the data
that we presented the our modeling from
the bccdc modeling group that we
presented on january 14th
when we put in the additional
restrictions
and we can see that we have followed
that trajectory for hospitalizations and
we're now starting to see the decrease
in senses so people in hospital with a
positive test as we would expect to see
because we took the measures that we did
and if we go to the next slide
our modeling then shows us that we have
the ability now with the amount of
immunity and the transmission patterns
that we're seeing to start lifting the
restrictions that we've had in place
particularly the additional ones we put
in place as we're trying to understand
the impact that omicron is going to have
so our next slide
ensuring balance and easing restrictions
is the way that we have gone about this
from the very beginning using the data
to make sure that we are doing um as
much as we need to do to keep things um
in
to to find that balance between
infections and opening up
so we are going to have an incremental
easing of restrictions and orders
starting tomorrow and i'll give you the
details of those in a minute
but there will be some things that will
remain in place and we will i will
review those in detail prior to middle
of march
prior to spring break
and again before easter in april
we know that for some people what we're
doing today will be really fast and it
will make them uncomfortable we know as
well for others it's not fast enough and
they would like to see things going back
to
as if the virus was no longer here but
the reality is that this virus continues
to circulate in our community and
because we have such a high level of
immunity through immunization
for most people that doesn't
lead to serious illness or
hospitalizations
and we need to respect that people need
to go at their own pace and businesses
will need to go at their own pace
depending on their own risk
as well our immunization campaigns will
continue as i've mentioned we now have
good data about how important that
booster dose is
also for protecting against infection
right now but also for the future in
addition very shortly we should have new
tools in new vaccines including the
novavax vaccine and the metacargo
vaccine which are more traditional
subunit vaccines that will be available
for those people who have concerns about
mrna vaccines and we're hoping to hear
news about that in the very near future
and that will be yet another option to
help people get through this phase and
protect us going into the future
so what is going to continue on our next
slide the protective measures that we
have used with success here in bc that
will continue for now
are our mass mandate in indoor public
spaces
when we have this amount of transmission
in our communities and we know that
those indoor spaces are where
we can transmit more easily that are
riskier settings that extra layer
protection becomes important
we also will continue to use the bc
vaccine card as a way of ensuring that
we're mitigating that risk in those
highest risk indoor settings and it will
rely on the coveted safety plans with
the important
backbone of the covet safety plans to
allow people to return to offices and
workplaces
and then starting on february 16th at 11
59 pm
in the next slide we will be
removing restrictions on all of the
restrictions on indoor personal
gatherings and that will mean that you
will make your own decisions based on
your risk and the risk in your family of
who you will have over into your home
and to have in
in vacation rentals and other properties
we are going to be
allowing again indoor and outdoor
organized gatherings so those are those
wedding receptions and parties and
celebrations of life that we have had to
curtail or put on hold for the last few
weeks they will be with the that with
the mask mandate and the bc vaccine card
be allowed at full capacity
and because of the amount of immunity
that we have and the protection that we
get through those will be able to go to
full capacity and no longer have those
requirements of remaining at tables so
that means mingling and dancing and all
of those other important things that
we've missed we'll be back
indoor seated events will go back to
full capacity we had put in
that 50 capacity at movie theaters and
arts events and sports events that will
go back to full capacity as we were
before we uh hit the same omicron wave
fitness centers adult sports dance and
swimming will also go back to full
capacity and we'll be removing those
restrictions we had on
on tournaments for adults
in this now as things are improving and
the risk is going down
and importantly
in restaurants and our food and
beverage serving
orders restaurants bars and nightclubs
will now be allowed to reopen and go
back in terms of restaurants to full
capacity with no limits of people at
tables and going back to mingling and
being able to have events in restaurants
and dancing
and it is because we have those those
layers of protection through the vaccine
card through our masking and through
those covid safety plans that we can go
back to full capacity in these settings
again
so for most people that will start on
thursday morning the 17th although um at
midnight on the
uh on february 16th
the orders that were in place will
expire
so we do have some protective measures
still in place and as i said these will
be reviewed to see if any of them or all
of them are still necessary and we're
committing to reviewing them again by
march 15th and letting people know where
we are then based on the data and the
surveillance that we have and again on
april 12th prior to the easter weekend
so along with the masks and the vaccine
card
we will be looking at the increasing
visitation
and looking at the restrictions that we
have on on additional social visits in
long-term care
we'll be working with our school and
child care and early childhood education
on the reviewing of the guidelines for k
to 12 and child care we'll be meeting
with faith leaders to review the the
some remaining restrictions we have in
and faith communities and there's two
orders on
child and youth overnight camps and the
industrial camps orders that we will be
reviewing as well as we move through the
next month
so that's where we are right now i want
to say how proud i am of people in
british columbia for stepping up and
doing what you have done to take care of
each other to follow the guidance that
we have we are at an exciting and
positive milestone
but we've had we have all sacrificed and
come through a lot in the last two years
and we want to move ahead slowly and
cautiously and thoughtfully and we need
to do this
to together to make sure that we're
respecting each other's comfort levels
as we move into this and we build that
confidence to come back together again
in so many ways that we need
so let's take this time to recognize our
progress and all that we have done
through this pandemic to turn the tide
on covet 19.
our long-term sustainable strategy about
recovery readiness and respect it's
about moving slowly and thoughtfully and
gradually getting back to all of the
things that we love
it means all of us continuing to be
accountable to each other
managing our own risks and equally
important protecting those around us
we are on track and we are progressing
well
so let's look to tomorrow with hope
and know
that optimism that we can increasingly
tr start living with this virus without
it disrupting so many aspects of our
life
but we can't
lose sight of the fact that we have some
ways to go yet
the journey ahead will be a challenge
and different for all of us but if we
continue to respect each other to be
kind to each other we will get through
this phase of it as well
this is
thank you very much dr henry and good
afternoon
today i'll provide an update on bc's
rapid test inventory healthcare workers
off sick last week and an update on
surgical postponements
first i want to reiterate the gratitude
to all british columbians who have
overwhelmingly
done the right thing over the past two
years
following public health orders and
guidance and most importantly getting
vaccinated it's because of these efforts
by all of us
that we are where we are today
regarding rapid tests up to the end of
february 11 2020 bc has received 15
million 318 thousand and six tests
also as of february 11
we had deployed 7 million 231
358 of these tests to key strategic
areas
this leaves a current inventory of eight
million eighty six thousand six hundred
and forty eight
as noted in previous weeks five hundred
fifty eight thousand six hundred and
forty eight of the current inventory are
not suitable for deployment for takeaway
or personal use and these tests will
continue to be used at the discretion of
medical health officers in the
appropriate settings to manage clusters
and outbreaks
that leaves 7 528 000 tests that are
suitable for self-administered use
in addition there's approximately 2 876
470 tests on route to british columbia
and now an additional 9 million 964
710 tests are scheduled to arrive over
the weeks to come but are not yet in
transit
but we await the additional 9.9 million
tests we will be working to deliver the
approximately 10.4 million tests that
have arrived or are in transit through
the following allocations
720 000
to cover 19 test sites across bc to
replenish their supply as you know
they've already received millions
two hundred thousand to replenish supply
at acute care centers for health care
workers and health authority employees
a hundred thousand to support testing
visitors and staff in long-term care and
assisted living in addition to the
approximately 1.74 million they have
already received
300 000 to support rural remote and
indigenous communities
300 000 for businesses and organizations
3.8 million more tests
kits to k-12 education
2.1 million more test kits for the
post-secondary education sector
these last allocations related to
education mark an important shift as
students will be offered in coming weeks
the opportunity to take home one five
test kit
for their and their family's future use
if they were to become symptomatic
assuming the in-transit delivery of 2.87
million tests arrived later this week we
also anticipate starting distribution at
no cost to citizens to the broader to
the broader community we will begin with
seniors carrying on our focus on higher
risk individuals but will expand to the
broader population as the inventory
continues to arrive
it's important to remember i know dr
henry will remind us that testing
continues to be something we do when we
have symptoms that hasn't changed
increased test availability means that
more members of the general population
will be able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness and to take action to limit
transmission to their friends family and
work including those at higher risk i'll
have more to say over the next week and
dr henry and i will have more to say on
the distribution over the next week
with respect to the impact of sickness
on health care workers we saw a decrease
in the number of staff with short-term
illness off sick 15 524
during the week of february 7th to 13th
by way of comparison from the previous
week we had 17
158
healthcare workers off sick that's 3438
and fraser health
2932 in interior help
1612 in northern health
1538 in the provincial health services
authority
2181 in vancouver coastal health
3273 in island health and 550 in
providence healthcare as you'll note in
particular interior health
proportionately that continues to be a
significant number and while it has come
down in the last couple of weeks it
continues to be higher than it normally
would be this time of year just to be
clear these are not this is not illness
from clovid19 we're talking about it's
all illness including covet 19 in
comparison to similar periods in
previous years it's a product come down
to about 20 percent higher
and now here's our surgical renewal
update uh health authorities report 6006
surgeries were completed from january
16th to 22nd we want to talk about the
most recent period from february 6th to
12th health authorities postponed 320
non-urgent scheduled surgeries that's 70
and fraser health three in northern
health
231 in the interior health authority 10
in island health and 6 in the provincial
health services authorities no surgeries
were postponed in vancouver coastal
health
all the efforts we've made to stop
kovid's rapid spread from using our
covets sense to getting vaccinated
consistently following public health
guidance have made a difference
because of those efforts where it's safe
to do so health authorities have been
able to start again booking and
completing surgeries that were postponed
we said patients will get calls to
rebook their surgeries they will all of
them will and that is exactly what is
starting to happen patients are starting
to get their calls patients are starting
to get their surgeries there will
continue to be some postponements
because of staffing or the need to
create capacity but is what is vital
right now as we all understand that our
work is not done and you can see that it
is not done all of us need to keep
making a difference that matters and as
we do this work that we do so well we
make the essential difference in the
lives of all patients who are waiting
for those calls and we think of them
today and all of the health care workers
who continue to do exceptional work
throughout our health care system and
with that i'll invite premier back to
the podium we're happy to take your
questions
thank you dr henry minister dix and
i know there'll be a a range of
questions and whoever is the most
appropriate person to answer them will
step up and
offer a solution to whatever conundrum
you have before you
thank you premiere as a reminder to me
on the phone line please press start one
to enter the queue you're limited to one
question and one follow-up first
question today is from richard zusman
global news
i look forward to solutions
many other jurisdictions in canada as
you are acutely aware are getting rid of
vaccine cards
ranging from alberta all the way to
quebec with the timeline
largely through this month and into
march
why is british columbia one of the
outliers here in terms of keeping the
vaccine card in place is this about
science or is it about
confidence slash trying to get people to
still get vaccinated
well i believe it's a combination of all
of those variables as you know
the vaccine card uptake in british
columbia was swift and it was
overwhelming and it gives people comfort
uh when they go out into social settings
particularly seated events
that the people that are around them
have taken the same measure to protect
themselves i'll allow dr henry to talk
about why this science is important but
again british columbians have been
comfortable to be outliers on a number
of fronts
and we've done so because we want to
ensure that the sacrifices that people
have made over the past two years are
not in vain and therefore a measured
approach is how we've
addressed all of these issues going back
to 2020 and we'll continue to do that i
believe that british columbians want us
to chart a bc course based on the
variables that come into play in our
communities based on the the level of
acceptance of the measures that have
come forward as as all three of us have
said repeatedly the success of of our
approach to covet has been a direct
result of british columbians
acknowledging that they can take
personal actions they can get vaccinated
they can follow public health guidelines
they can wash their hands they can stay
at home when they're sick and most
importantly they can respect other
people's comfort levels and the
immunization card has a role to play in
that i don't know if you want to add the
science piece to that
so we've always had a bit of a a
different approach in use of the vc
vaccine card and it's for very specific
settings that are the higher risk
settings that are indoor settings where
people often have to take their mass off
for a period of time
or when you're in settings uh that are
indoors
with people that you don't know and you
don't know their vaccine status so those
are
those are important things and what
we've done is we have taken off
restrictions on capacity limits for
example because we have the mitigation
of the the bc vaccine card so we're
different from ontario from quebec in
that regard so it has played a role it's
played a role in reducing and not
eliminating the risk of transmission and
we know especially with omicron that it
can still be transmitted although that
is less and particularly less
in people who have their booster dose on
board as well
but we also know that in those indoor
settings where it's applied
where we can have quite large numbers of
people together that even if there's
some transmission the amount of immunity
from vaccination means it's not going to
be spread as widely and we're not going
to get people getting seriously ill and
ending up in hospital at the same degree
so there are reasons that we're keeping
it in place but really it's
being able to take away capacity limits
and still have mitigation of risk in
those settings so we've used it somewhat
differently having said that
we'll also be reassessing
when its value is no longer needed and
it has to do with the amount of
transmission we're seeing in our
communities and where we no longer need
to mitigate that risk and people are
more comfortable
with being together in those indoor
discretionary settings
richard do you have a followup
i'm just wondering what enforcement
tools will be in place especially when
it comes to mask wearing we know it was
already challenging at places like
canucks games now you add night clubs
and bars and other weddings where people
are going to want to get sort of face to
face how do you enforce the mask mandate
and how quickly could the province pivot
back if we see a resurgence in covid in
the fall dr henry as you have alluded to
in the past could we see these
restrictions come back as respiratory
season comes back next fall
yeah so i in terms of you know
reinforcement we've also seen very much
that people understand the use of masks
in those settings they feel comfortable
with them all of us have gotten used to
where we
wear masks so i don't believe
enforcement is going to be a large issue
i know there are some places that are
trying to make points around these
things but really it you know people
speak with their comfort level and we
expect people to do that and to manage
their own risk in most settings
yeah and
as i talked about we're not out of this
pandemic yet we are very much i believe
in a transition phase and so much of
that has to do with the amount of
immunity that we have here and across
the country
but it's not the same everywhere around
the world so it is inevitable that we
will see some waning of immunity that
we'll see new variants arise and so what
we are focused on is how do we manage
this is
yet another serious respiratory illness
along with influenza along with rsv that
we expect to have impacts in our
communities during the respiratory
season and i hope it will be the fall
and not before that
but what uh what we need to look at is
you know who's most at risk who will be
most at risk during that period of time
given what variants we're seeing so we
will be really focusing on our
surveillance systems on making sure
we've continuing our vaccine
effectiveness studies on understanding
who's most at risk from whatever the
next variant is that arises but i don't
believe we will have to go back to broad
societal measures
unless something dramatically different
happens
we have a baseline of immunity that we
know protects people from serious
illness so what we will focus on is how
do we best protect those people who are
most at risk so whether it's seniors in
long-term care and adding it into the
measures that we take
around other outbreaks in long-term care
homes
and adjusting our communicable disease
plans that we do for managing outbreaks
of measles for example in in schools and
adding covet into those
those types of strategies that we have
going into the fall
and we'll be spending more time
with people on how do you understand
your own risk and when
we're seeing transmission in your
community what you do to keep yourself
safe so there's lots of things that we
will do
to support people who are more at risk
of severe illness and our hope and
expectation is we won't have to have
broad societal measures because we know
they have health and and well-being
impacts as well
anybody else wants to ask
questions ctv
hi there um dr henry i heard you talk
there about some public
health measures that will continue for
years ahead just wondering if you can
shed some light on what those measures
would be specifically would it be you
know to protect those higher risk
populations or you know are we talking
about perhaps um mouth
yeah no we're talking about the basics
of how we protect ourselves and you know
these are the things that i've said
hundreds and hundreds of times things
like staying home when you're sick but
how do we facilitate that because we
have learned that it's not that easy for
many people so things like having
mandatory sick leave policies make a big
difference in being able to support that
it means
you know washing your hands regularly
covering your mouth when you cough and
wearing masks in certain situations and
that is culturally
what's been done in in other communities
and i think we now all have learned that
so it may be important if there's high
levels of transmission in the community
but it will be based on guidance and
advice not on orders
at least going forward that's our
expectation so all of those important
things that we do to prevent
transmission of influenza of other
things
will be important and we'll just need to
reinforce those during periods of time
where we see higher respiratory illness
transmission
do you have a follow-up bender yeah just
wondering uh when it comes to math um i
know some other places are
uh kind of dropping math requirements uh
for younger kids i'm just wondering you
know with math still required in indoor
public places for those five plus now in
bc is there any chance we could see uh
by age group those requirements being
lifted or do you envision it being all
at once and just also for the premiere
um you're aware of course of the the
ongoing protest and are you worried at
all that this could make protesters
think either that their
actions have worked or that it could
further embolden uh other actions
yeah i hope we we've shown that it's the
actions that all of us have taken over
the last
months and and two years now that have
made a difference to getting us where we
are um in terms of masks uh it is that
you know i think really important we've
talked about i've talked about this
quite a few times you know when you have
higher rates of transmission in the
community and there's still really high
rate now
all the different layers become more
important as those
rates go down it becomes
less important in many different
situations to have every single one of
those layers so we will be looking at at
mask wearing and where we can switch to
it being that recommendation for when
you're in certain settings in certain
conditions
versus having a mandate that requires it
in public public indoor spaces at all
times so that's something that we'll be
reviewing in march and
you know and and or april depending on
where we get to in in terms of
transmission in the community by by
march
so with respect to the restrictions that
were lifted will be lifted tomorrow
those were designed to be temporary
those were designed to address the
omicron wave which we had
little or no knowledge of when it
arrived in december
and the decision to pick this day to
make this announcement dr henry minister
dix
talked about this in early january this
is not brought upon
uh the public today by any protest any
uh
horn honking any encampments it was
brought about because this was the plan
we had when we brought in the
restrictions to protect people at a time
of uncertainty you'll remember
at christmas how uncertain we were case
counts were spiking hospitalizations
were increasing and we were uncertain
about how we were going to be addressing
yet another wave of covet 19 but we said
at the beginning these were temporary
measures to protect people
we said in early january that we would
revisit the question just prior to the
family day-long weekend and that's
exactly what we've done we have been
driven from the beginning on the best
available science to protect people to
keep our economy moving and to ensure
that all of us got out of this together
and and uh
poll after poll after poll for two years
has demonstrated that british columbians
are comfortable with an approach that
includes them uh which we've done with
faith groups uh the three of us have
engaged with faith leaders from a
multitude of denominations for the past
two years to ensure that we're trying to
get the balance right so people can
continue to do the things that are
important to them we've been managing
sector by sector whether it be k-12
child care the construction industry
hospitality trying to engage with people
to get the best outcomes possible and
that's what we'll continue to do it's
been successful uh to the to the
greatest degree possible because
everyone bought into it and that again
is confirmed time after time there are
those that disagree a narrow sliver of
the population disagrees and as i said
earlier we can disagree but don't be
disagreeable the uh encampments in
ottawa the occupation of our cap
nation's capital is uh
disappointing to every canadian to see a
cache of automatic weapons
seized at a canadian border point is
disturbing for all canadians and i
believe that the vast majority want to
get along respect each other and again
determine everyone's comfort level and
get on with your lives that's what we
all aspire to do each and every day and
that's what we're going to continue to
do here in bc
myra whiten the t
e
hi
hi thank you for taking my question um
i'm a bit curious about
you noting that everyone has to go on at
their own pace
um a lot of british columbians i've
spoken to are expressing that they feel
they don't have the tools to make an
accurate risk decision especially those
that are immunocompromised who feel that
even daily activities are moving at a
pace that is putting them at risk
without their consent or having another
option
are you as these measures
loosen gradually are you planning to
make rapid tests available widely to the
public in the immediate future and also
are there any plans to
open up pcr testing eligibility back to
the general public not just high risk
individuals
yeah so a couple of things on that
it is really important that we recognize
that there are people who even with the
vaccination
still remain at risk and those are
people who also are at risk of many
other things and in many cases they are
having to take additional precautions
for themselves and and we need to
understand that and i've talked about
this quite a few times especially since
omicron
how important it is for us to recognize
there may be people at risk that we
don't even know um that are our
colleagues at work that are
our friends in our social networks and
so that's why we are saying respect
people's comfort levels why we have some
of those important measures in place
right now like mask wearing in certain
situations like the coveted safety plans
because we're not through a period yet
where
the risk is low enough
and going forward though we will have to
think about how do we not have to put on
broad restrictions on everybody so that
we can be inclusive of people who have
immune compromising conditions and that
will mean that it will be important in
some situations that
you know mask wearing will be something
that some people do on an ongoing basis
and you know keeping gathering small we
look at
going
making that choice about going to a
social gathering versus
focusing on on other settings like our
work setting in our school setting so
those are personal choices that we will
have to make as we understand the
broader context of transmission and
we're working around
with tools to help support people and
how to make those decisions and i'll be
talking more about that in the next few
weeks
yes we are as minister dix indicated
we're expecting quite a lot more of the
at-home rapid tests to be available in
the coming weeks and we're going to
focus on making sure they're available
for free to people who are in those
higher risk groups particularly by age
or people who've been identified as
clinically extremely vulnerable we know
that we have distribution now that's
going to start it already that will be
going out for children
through schools so they will be more
available and people who are immune
compromised or
who are older
they are people that may
benefit from the treatments that are
coming online as well and that's where
the connection to pcr testing becomes so
so important so we will be ensuring that
those people have priority access to pcr
testing if they develop symptoms and
these are all things that were were
titrating right now as we're coming
through this wave but it'll be really
important as we're going into
the next wave
so that we know we have systems in place
for people who are
clinically vulnerable to to kovids that
they can get a test rapidly and can get
access to treatment rapidly so those are
things we're working on right now
myra do you have a follow-up
yeah
yeah dr henry you know over the weekend
yesterday we saw 17 people um pass away
due to covid
just in that three-day period and you
know as omicron continues to spread as
you're aware about one in ten cases
conservatively end up with long-term
health complications including long
covet and other post-viral illness
with the gradual easing of restrictions
how much of that long-term illness and
death should british colombians expect
you know public health officials to
accept um as the restrictions continue
to open and is there
a benchmark or a
[Music]
figure that would give you pause
as you reevaluate the restrictions that
are in place
yeah so
really challenging questions and
when we look at the people who have died
it is sadly
overwhelmingly people who are um
are seniors and elders some of them in
long-term care and of course we we count
everybody uh in long-term care who dies
within 30 days of a positive cova test
so
many people are dying with coven not
necessarily because of it but it is
important to to recognize that but we
are also seeing
unvaccinated people in particular who
don't have that degree of protection
from severe illness who are dying and
some of them younger in their 30s and
40s and that's important to recognize
we we do know
that with the the high rates of
transmission in the community
this small this number of people that
we're seeing
could be so much worse if we didn't have
that number of people protected through
vaccination i'm not being very eloquent
in how i'm saying this
but it is a reminder to us that this is
not an innocuous virus and it can have
very severe effects particularly in
people who who don't have a strong
ability to respond don't have a strong
immune response don't have the
protection of vaccination and even
for some people who are immune
compromised or who are older so we do
need to continue to take measures to
protect them and that's why you're
seeing the measures that we still have
in place in long-term care to reduce
risk and
the the vaccine card things like mask
wearing and staying away if we're ill
ourselves
a couple of things that we're learning
about long covet
people who are infected and and there's
still a lot unknown about omicron and
long-term effects some people do get
very sick it's not an innocuous illness
as i've said a number of times
but we do know the risk of having
long-term symptoms that persist
when you're vaccinated is at least half
and we've seen that through other waves
that seems to hold true for delta as
well our surfer omicron as well so
vaccination again is another thing that
protects you from long covert
really important we still don't have a
good understanding of children and
longer term impacts of this virus and
infections in children so that's an
important thing that we're still trying
to get information about
and we'll need to monitor this over the
long haul it does remind us that we have
downsides of opening up but we also know
that there's impacts societal impacts on
health and well-being and mental health
from some of the restrictions that are
in place so it is finding that balance
between those two
next question is from less lane times
colonist
oh thank you
dr henry
our
health professionals in bc still under
orders to get vaccinated by march 24th
or is that aspect of it under
review with some of the other stuff
through march and april
no the the healthcare worker
immunization
is still in place as is
the the work with the colleges around
registered health professionals and i
think it's a really important thing that
we all it's not just for getting through
this wave right now it's for that longer
term protection as we
learn to live with this virus over time
so it is important it is still in place
the order will be published very soon
for regulated health professionals and i
will say that you know one of the things
that i was looking at very carefully
with the colleges is having other
options available so i mentioned that
we are hopeful that we'll hear from
health canada about two other
vaccines that
will be available hopefully very shortly
uh the novofax vaccine and medicago
which
are really important options and
effective vaccines for people who
either can't or aren't able to take the
mrna vaccines
follow-up less
yeah you've been quite clear that we're
nowhere near out of this
it's going to run for a year or more
and that
another wave at least one is expected uh
is there any
uh you're confident of that but you're
also confident that you won't need the
same level of mandates and restrictions
to deal with what's coming up is it just
purely the the
vaccines that lead you to that
confidence that you don't have to
flip on some of this and go back to
restrictions next fall
um i guess it's it's a combination of
things it's it's understanding immunity
and what we're learning about it longer
term immunity and and how that is
maintained even with a radically
different
variant of the virus
being omicron
there's many things we we don't know
whether we'll need a booster dose uh
whether that's everybody or just people
who are most at risk and people who have
these stronger immune systems will be
longer lasting you know some of the
decisions we made
quite early on in the immunization
program have proved to be very
important in longer term protection that
interval between dose one and dose two
and now the interval between those two
and the booster dose is has shown to be
really important but there's lots of
things we don't yet know that i'm
spending quite a lot of time looking
into and with uh with my colleagues
things like
you know the nasal spray vaccines that
are under development could that be
an option as a booster dose to help
stimulate our mucosal immunity in the
nose and the back of the throat you know
that's where omicron has been attacked
attacking for example
and does that
lead to a strong enough boost of
the cell-mediated immunity so there's
many things that we don't yet know but
we do we can see
that it is that high level of
vaccination that has allowed us to
weather this omicron wave and we did put
in some restrictions but we didn't have
to do things like
lockdowns and other things because we
had that high level of immunity and we
layered on some of the other measures
in in certain settings as well and that
that made a difference we also need to
really um we we've understood and we've
come to see how fragile our health care
system is and i know the minister is
working very hard on that to make sure
that we have that capacity
to to be able to care for people with a
a surge that is inevitable to come but
but i do believe knowing what i know
about
pandemics and how we've weathered them
and all of the scenarios that we have
seen over the last two years that we
will see sort of an oscillating and yes
there will be
there will be waves and troughs of covid
it's
likely to have different impacts in
different years depending on how much
the virus changes over time
rob buffum ctv vancouver island
okay we are moving on to our last
question mira baines cvc
okay so i'm hoping to get answers in
english and in french
dr henry you're indicating that the
current safety rules for the k-12 system
will be reviewed in march and april but
how likely is it that those restrictions
will be lifted by the end of the school
year there are parents in bc who say
they've never been inside the the school
their child attends to volunteer to meet
a teacher or
go watch an event
yeah so i i i
i can tell you that
there's likely to be some changes sooner
rather than later and we've been working
with my team and the bccdc have been
working with the k-12 steering committee
and at looking at exactly this you know
how do we make it as as normal as
possible in experience we recognize that
that's so important for growth and
development especially for younger
children and now that we have
vaccination available to all school-age
children the risk profile changes
and we've learned from omicron there's
no such thing as zero risk in a school
setting in any setting really so it's
about how do we manage it in a way that
allows for full participation in school
activities without some of those
restrictions
i know that they are working right now
on
things like spectators at sports and
we'll be hearing more from the education
committee and the education minister
around that very soon
so these are all questions that i don't
have answers for you yet
but that we are looking at how do we
make sure that the k-12 experience
aligns with what we're seeing in the
community and is a is the best that we
can do for for kids i will also say
because i'm starting to get questions
already that we we are very aware that
uh graduation will be coming up in a few
months and how can we make that um again
aligned with what we're seeing and risk
in the community and
and a more normal experience for for
grads this year too
commemorative
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes and
again in english and in french uh dr
henry at this point 55 percent of kids 5
to 11 in bc have received one dose of a
vaccine is that number an acceptable
level for you and what if anything is
being done to try to get that percentage
up and will it be necessary to make sure
more kids get vaccinated
yeah no obviously that's not an
acceptable level
we do really want to protect young
children as i mentioned we still don't
have a lot of insight into the long-term
impacts on younger children uh from
infection even though it does thankfully
seem to be relatively mild in younger
kids
um so it is important we do know um that
vaccination is safe in that age group
the
the pediatric formulation formulation is
working well
lots of kids are now getting dose too
and that's important it's important to
help get back to those normal activities
as we're still seeing transmission and
to
normalize things for for young uh kids
in schools as well as their social
connections so we are doing quite a few
things it's very community dependent as
the the booster doses have decreased and
we're making sure that the pharmacies
are ramping up to be able to provide
booster doses for adults and older
children um we're looking at more
targeted
clinics for for younger children where
they can have all of their questions
answered and i really do want to
encourage parents we we know lots now
about the safety of these pediatric
vaccines and how well they work and talk
to your health care provider talk to
your pediatrician your pharmacist
your public health nurse
and get your questions answered and it's
very important to protect our youngest
kids as well
ifb just keeps fading here just to say
there are appointments available today
at the get vaccinated website or call
1-833-838-2323 and get your appointment
today
because um
this is an example 93.8
percent i believe of adults to receive
their first dose immunization against
covet 19 93.5 percent but we think 6.5
on vaccinate is too high and why do we
think that because you're 30 times as
likely 30 times 3-0 is likely to get
into crit to be in critical care if
you're not vaccinated
as
we'll see you soon